[Musique]
donc je m'appelle sedef ecer je suis
d'origine turque j'écris dans les deux
langues en langue française et en langue
turque
je suis plutôt auteur dramatique et
scénariste aussi il ya beaucoup de
débats aujourd'hui autour de la
francophonie il faut pas oublier
l'histoire il faut pas oublier ce que ça
a voulu dire dans le temps mais
aujourd'hui je pense que le la langue
française est vraiment est aussi un
espace qui véhicule des valeurs des
idées c'est aussi la langue qui nous
unit et il ya autant de français que de
que d'auteurs francophones donc chacun
de nous inventons je pense son autre
français à nous avec notre langue
maternelle à nous j'aime les comédies
pessimistes et les tragédies optimiste
je crois donc du coup j'aime bien
trouver le équilibre entre ces deux
choses je me dis jamais que je vais
écrire des sujets politiques mais c'est
malgré moi un moment donné ce que
j'écris devient politique je sais pas
pourquoi mais il ya aussi peut-être une
chose c'est que quand on est femme plus
on vient d'un pays dans les rapports
nord-sud plus du sud et plus d'un pays
musulman va forcément tout ce que vous
écrivez prend un poids qui pourrait être
qualifié de politique ou d'engager en
tout cas
[Musique]
jusqu'à là quelques années quand on me
disait vous êtes une hauteur femmes je
voulais même pas entendre ça parce que
je pense que déjà il ya pas une écriture
plus féminine que masculine mais je
pense qu'aujourd'hui nous devons être
vraiment très très vigilant par rapport
aux droits acquis et donc du coup je
prends tous les moyens possibles pour
faire entendre les voix féminines l'ice
a cédé publie chaque année
les analyses des chiffres et on voit
bien les tendances profondes c'est à
dire que à la tête de l'état et
nationaux n'y a pas de femmes à la tête
des scènes nationales ya à peu près 30%
de femmes les metteurs en scène ou
doivent représenter le metteur en scène
femmes et les auteurs femmes entre 25 et
30%
donc les auteurs dramatiques femme aussi
donc forcément oui bien sûr il faut se
battre plus quand on est une femme pour
raconter des histoires j'ai l'impression
[Musique]